vous avez pu le voir dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi un dans son humeur trier
s'est déclaré dans le 16e arrondissement
de paris provoquant la mort de 10
personnes 30 personnes sont blessées on
vous a résumé tout ça en images et on
aura avec vous dans un instant natalia
redit 45 ans habitante de l'immeuble
depuis un an et demi et clément vasseur
qui dormait sur la chez sa compagne ils
vont tous nous raconter sont vraiment
des témoins qui étaient dans l'immeuble
à ce moment là et ils vont nous raconter
la genèse de ce de cet incendie
meurtrier
regardez le récap est un terrible drame
qui a secoué le 16e arrondissement de
paris dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
et on commence avec cet incendie cette
nuit dans le 16e arrondissement alors qu
il l incendie n'est toujours pas
maîtrisé un incendie extrêmement violent
qui s'est donc déclaré un incendie qui a
fait 10 morts un bilan provisoire qui
pourrait s'alourdir dans les prochaines
heures
c'est un peu après 00h30 qu'un riverain
a appelé les pompiers pour intervenir
sur un incendie dans l'ouest de paris
très vite sur place les soldats du feu
ont dû faire face à un incendie d'une
très grande ampleur qui malgré la
mobilisation de près de 250 hommes aura
mis plus de six heures à être maîtrisé
au total plus de 50 personnes ont pu
être sauvées par l'intervention des
pompiers christophe castaner le ministre
de l'intérieur s'est rendu sur place dès
9 heures et il a salué le travail des
pompiers de paris devraient saluer
l'immense mobilisation de sa propre
enquête paris sur place les témoins sont
sous le choc
où s'est retranché dans un coin
il ya des gens qui sont montés à bout de
bras jusqu'à mois pour échapper aux
flammes
un incendie qui serait d'origine
criminelle d'après les premiers éléments
de l'enquète dans le viseur de la
justice une femme de 40 ans présentant
des antécédents psychiatriques qui a été
interpellé la nuit du drame alors
qu'elle tentait de mettre le feu à des
poubelles durant l'intervention des
secours
à l'origine de ce coup de folie une
altercation avec un voisin pompier qui
lui demandait d'arrêter de frapper à sa
porte aujourd'hui on a appris que la
suspecte avait déjà fait l'objet de
trois procédures judiciaires dont une en
2016 pour l'incendié d'un magasin autre
information l'immeuble a été placé sous
surveillance la raison les étages
supérieurs pourraient désormais
s'effondrer en raison de la violence de
l'incendié ce soir des rescapés témoigne
dans tpm p merci nathalie merci d'être
là merci également à clément vous avez
22 ans et nathalie vous êtes habitante
de l'immeuble depuis un an et demi
clément donc 22 ans vous dormez ce
soir-là chercher votre compagne alors un
capitule hâtive des faits donc c'est
passé dans la nuit de lundi à mardi aux
alentours de zéro heure trente
donc le feu s'est déclenché dans un
immeuble de huit étages du 16e
arrondissement le drame selon le voisin
donc pompier de profession l' incendie
se serait serait survenu après une
dispute le voisin donc se plaignant à
plusieurs reprises à la voisine de
nuisance sonore musique trop forte
il aurait demandé plusieurs fois à la
voisine en question de bien vouloir
éteindre sa musique le ton serait monté
entre les deux voisins connaissant le
passé psychiatrique de sa voisine le
voisin pompier de métier aurait appelé
la police aux alentours de 23h 50 et au
bout de 40 minutes les policiers au bout
du fil finissent par julie que ce n'est
pas une situation d'urgence bon ils ont
passé c'est ça aussi voilà c'est il
propose aux pompiers de partir passer la
nuit ailleurs avec sa compagne est
paraît-il donc que le pompier leur avais
dit que ça allait mal se terminer
apparemment cette affaire donc plus tard
dans la soirée des policiers viennent
sur place et n'embarque pas la femme au
poste il ya des procédures a donc
forcément peut pas embarquer quelqu'un
comme ça et parce que j'ai entendu des
gens dire oui la police a mal fait son
travail tout ça ils ont juste suivi les
procédures on peut pas voilà c'est pas
possible on peut pas faire ça comme ça
donc c'est vrai que il les a mis en
garde le pompier mais ils peuvent pas
interpellé comme c'est quelqu'un tant
qu'il n'y a rien eu parce que c'est très
calmement c'est ça exactement elle les a
reçus très calmement alors nathalie vous
êtes dans l'immeuble depuis un an et
demi est ce que vous vous dites vous
doutiez aussi que ça allait mal se
terminer comme l'a dit ce pompier pas du
tout pas du tout au moment où il ya eu
l'altercation
on les a entendus
député e
mais on n'a pas du tout pensé une
seconde que ça allait obliger comme
d'âge évidemment alors qu'est ce que
vous vous
la suspecte donc c'est une femme donc de
41 ans est ce que vous avez eu des
problèmes avec elle ou pas du tout ça
mais jamais je vois je vais croiser
parce que j'ai vu sa photo donc je sais
qui c'est mais j'ai vous vous habitiez à
l'un des paquets l'état jeu par exemple
c'était troisième étage et elle l est et
au au deuxième étage à dos quand mais si
jamais il n'y a jamais eu de problème on
est très nombreux dans l'immeuble donc
on croise beaucoup de gens mais on les
connaît peu en fait
alors donc vous avez été évacué par les
pompiers commencent à se dérouler parce
que c'est en pleine nuit
vous êtes vous êtes mariés vous avez une
famille j'ai une fille d'accord vous
étiez donc avec votre fiche est
maintenant elle n'était pas là ce soir
vous étiez seul on était que tous les
deux d'accord et donc qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en fait on l'a entendu
casser des assiettes après l'altercation
on avait juste
on a juste été voir ce qui se passait
parce que c'était un petit peu violent
je me rappelle des mots qu'elles lui
avaient dit qu'ils étaient si tu bouges
tu es mort d'accord et après plus rien
en fait après on a touché dans
l'appartement d'accord et donc là vous
entendez ça et quand est ce que vous
avez il faisait une vous dernier comme
le feu s'est déclaré
voilà tout à fait on dormait on a été
scotché et on a été réveillés par la
lame l'alarmé incendie
d'accord si donc c'est le fruit de la
lampe qui nous a réveillés et à ce
moment là on a remarqué qu'il y avait
déjà beaucoup de fumée dans
l'appartement
quelle était votre votre réflexe que
vous êtes au troisième étage vous avez
fait quoi on a voulu aller les verts la
porte on pouvait pas sortir parce qu'il
y avait déjà des flammes derrière la
porte
abra rente et du coup ont annoncé les
pompiers
les pompiers étaient déjà là
dès que l'alarmé sonnait donc une heure
je pense une heure du matin
voilà c'est ça je pense à veiller très
très rapidement s'est dit qu'est ce qui
se passe donc le feu était déjà bien
venir déclaré les pompiers étaient déjà
là bas et en fait je suis avec elle la
première personne témoin c'est minuit 40
à peu près qu'elle a appelé les pompes
les premiers pompiers
mais en fait ils sont arrivés me semble
avec des camions avec des échelles sauf
que dans l'âme l'appartement ce avec une
cour intérieure
en fait ils ont dû prendre toutes les
échelles avec leurs mains bras en fait
ils n'ont pas pu rentrer avec les
camions dans l'appartement adacore d'eau
qui dévalent les échelles dans la cour
intérieure et donc c'est vrai que ça a
pris du temps en fait donc en gros quand
ça a sonné on allait à la porte d'entrée
j'ai essayer de l'ouvrir
heureusement j'ai pas réussi et en fait
taxées louvre y avait des flammes juste
derrière il y avait plein de fumée qui
rentrait donc on sentait qu'on allait
pas respirer donc j'ai fermé la première
porte après on aller dans le salon la
direccte fermé la porte peut aussi on
allait dans la chambre donc on avait
fermé toutes les portes possibles
on n'a pas eu le temps de mettre de
linge mouillé parce qu'il avait trop de
fumée dans le salon sinon ça se fixer et
on a ouvert la vôtre vous êtes dit quoi
ce moment est-ce que vous êtes dit
nathalie est ce que vous êtes dit à mon
avis on va pas s'en sortir
ah c'était un peu la panique c'est sûr
que là c'est de rester calmes mais en
fout on voyait bien qu'il n'y avait pas
de moyen de sortir par par les escaliers
pas voilà c'est sûr qu'on a n'a eu peur
même temps restons des siens de rester
calme on était et donc les pompiers mais
non évacuées comment parle pas le balcon
pas le jour comment s'est passé vous
avez vous êtes vous avez été évacués
c'est rapidement vous avez attendu
combien de temps dans le vent les
flammes dont le en 25 minutes 25 minutes
sa dette est vraiment très très long
vous avez passé des coups de fil à des
gens vous avez dit non on est resté en
ligne avec les pompiers en fait qui nous
disait ce qu'on doit faire et vous
disais quoi les pompiers il faut faire
il vous arrive faire quoi il sait nous
localiser aussi savoir où on était pour
pouvoir dire à leurs collègues
et bien c'est faire quoi de rester dans
une pièce de faire quoi d'aller près du
balcon et or est resté là pour respirer
mais auparavant ils ont conseillé de
mettre des linges de vos sous la porte
mouillez d'accorder la chine apporte
rien d'accord et puis on ferait en fait
juste rester au maximum calme dont le
corps parfois j'ai un peu honte
trembloter vite fait mais on était super
calme puis bas instinctivement c'est
juste habillée
moi c'est plus mon téléphone nathalie
aussi on a à l'est près du balcon ali le
chien dans le sac à main c'est tout ce
qu'on a pu prendre parce que vous aviez
du mal de plus en plus de mal à respirer
vous sur cette semaine en plus
oppressant même au balcon fallait
filtrer l'air avec le pull parce que
sinon on n'aurait pas d'heure même avec
le balcon vers un gant tellement il y
avait de fumée qui arrivait vers parce
que toute la droite était en train de
brûler en fait vous arriver aujourd'hui
à à dormir à dormir
calmement est ce que vous arrivez à a
essayé de passer à autre chose ou pas
c'est vrai que c'est très récent
ou est-ce que vous êtes pensez que vous
allez il pensait bien sûr avis non ah
non non ça me dit on va faire une séance
de 2ème d'ailleurs une forme d'hypnose
ça marche super violent des greffés pour
effacer les images
et puis après en fait la première nuit
j'ai rien capté ans aux images je
pouvais imaginer tout ce que je voulais
donc j'ai dit non il faut que super
rapidement je passe à autre chose et
donc on se concentre énormément surtout
ce qu'on veut construire à faire
maintenant et on veut plutôt faire
passer ses messages je suis allé andere
il ya eu des victimes
donc 37 personnes blessées dont dix
pompiers sur dans les victimes poupaud
vous connaissez forcément des personnes
alors en fait aujourd'hui on n'a pas le
nom des victimes bien sûr
on sait pas encore qui est qui est là
qui n'est pas là il ya des gens qui sont
disparus mais vous n'aviez jamais aucun
problème avec 7,7 suspecte à la personne
suspectée de demander des engueulades un
petit peu dans l'immeuble vous écrit le
soir où des mets sept états s'étaient
passées de personnes là c'étaient
d'autres mais jean-michel la question
une petite bête mais dans ces moments là
est ce qu'on essaie de sauver des objets
personnels des albums photos on sait que
tout va être détruit est ce qu'on essaye
de sauver des choses voilà je n'avais
pas on n'était pas sûr on pense toujours
que ça va s'arranger que d'accord dont
vous êtes parti comme ça quand on est
parti comme ça est actuellement vous
allez être vous être relogées comment
est ce que le fait parce que l'imam
n'est plus accessible donc comment est
ce que vous êtes logis ben là on est
chez un proche notamment chez le père de
ma fille va accueillir tous les deux
très gentiment on a préféré ça que aller
à l'hôtel parce que la mairie nous a
proposé d'aller des assurances pardon
voila voila je ne les hôtels mais pour
cinq jours donc on préférait être
entourés de nos proches et c'est par la
suite on verra comment alors on voulait
bien sûr on a une pensée bien sûr pour
les victimes bien sûr de cet incendie et
bien sûr on voudrait rappeler encore le
temps minable travail des pompiers
voilà qui va sauver la vie on avoue
entre autres et il ya dix pompiers
blessés on pense très très fort à eux et
je vous le dis il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de pompiers qui sont voilà qui pendant
les interventions subissent des attaques
d d d insulte franchement les pompiers y
sont avec nous ils sont avec vous et
heureusement que les pompiers parce que
mine de rien il sauve des vies tous les
jours et il en fait leur vie en danger
et on pense fortement aux dix pompiers
qui ont été blessés avec 250 pompiers
mobilisés sur cet incendie merci en tout
cas
[Applaudissements]